la terre fait chine et le projecteur sur
les deux français mise en cause dans la
sphère à 2 explique le cas max théret et
le cas face et cela invité du journal
pierre joxe il répond toujours à propos
de cette affaire à la polémique entre le
journal le monde et l'elysée hommage à
salvador dali en fin de journal avec une
question comment sera réglé le difficile
héritage du génie sur réalise
neuf noms pour le csa ils sont
maintenant tous connu il y a beaucoup de
surprises le président ce sera jacques
boutet
puis en direct sur antenne 2 dans ce
journal la place de la concorde dévoile
ses formes et met à jour ses statuts
restauré depuis deux ans
bonsoir et tout d'abord la sphère
pechiney qui chaque jour prend un peu
plus d'ampleur ce soir antenne de braque
le projecteur sur deux personnages clés
de cette affaire les deux français mise
en cause
max théret d'une part et patrice pelât
l'ami du président de l'autre et puis
troisième élément pierre joxe le
ministre de l'intérieur répondra dans
quelques instants à propos de cette
polémique entre le journal le monde et
l'elysée mais si vous voulez bien
prenons les choses dans l'ordre
ce soir véronique auger a pu recueillir
les éléments de défense de max théret
c'est l'un des personnages clés de la
faire je vous le disais ce serait selon
certains l'un de ces fameuses initiés
qui aurait réalisé de gros bénéfices
au moment du rachat de triangle par
péchiney véronique auger c'est ici à
deux pas de la tour eiffel fort loin de
la bourse que max théret a installé sa
très discrète compagnie parisienne de
placement une société financière
spécialisée dans la gestion de fonds
pour entreprises et riches particuliers
aujourd'hui max théret préfèrent se
taire pas de déclaration officielle
devant les caméras avant la sortie du
rapport de la cob
d'abord il est fatigué il se relève à
peine d'un infarctus et il a 76 ans
ensuite en privé il affirme être
totalement serein oui il a acheté 32300
actions de la société triangle oui il
les a acquises
trois jours avant l'opéra de pechiney
sur le titre oui il a fait du 500% en
trois jours argent qu'il a déjà en poche
d'ailleurs mais dit-il
c'est grâce à son flair et au hasard et
ils argumentent début octobre
il est à new york il entend dire
beaucoup de bien de triangle numéro un
mondial de l'emballage le 17 octobre
il découvre cette lettre confidentielle
les experts y affirme que pechiney
s'apprête à prendre une taille
européenne le 27 octobre
les sociétés metal box et carnot
s'unissent triangle n'est plus le plus
fort dans l'emballage pour max théret
ses propriétaires doivent le vendre ou
le faire grossir dans les deux cas
pense-t-il
le titre va grimper il ne passera ses
ordres que 15 jours plus tard à cause de
son infarctus
dernier argument cette lettre son
intermédiaire à londres confirme qu'il a
limité ses achats à 11 $ l'action
si j'avais été initiée dit il j'aurais
acheté à beaucoup plus cher sachant que
le titre allait grimper à 56 dollars
enfin max théret confirme il a donné le
tuyau à son ami peu là vers le 11
novembre
si max théret a du flair ces affaires
souvent procurer des soucis le fondateur
de la fnac n'a pas pu empêcher le
naufrage du quotidien de gauche de matin
de paris son dernier achat celui de
pathé cinéma est déjà forte critique et
on l'accuse d'avoir servi de marchepied
à deux hommes d'affaires italiens
messieurs parity et berlusconi
l'autre français mise en cause dans
cette affaire c'est roger patrice pelât
l'ami du président at il acheté dix
mille ou cinquante mille actions c'est
toute la question le monde samedi
dernier le soupçonnaient d'en avoir
acheté 40 milles par une filière de
banques suisses mais la banque en
question dément
françoise joly il n'a rien changé à ses
habitudes
bonjour à faire ou pas roger patrice
pelât semblait ce matin ce sera une
sérénité peut être renforcée par les
doutes qui entourent les informations du
journal le monde
le quotidien a affirmé samedi que
patrice pelât aurait acquis non plus dix
mille mais cinquante mille actions
triangle ses titres supplémentaires
auraient été achetés de façon détournée
à partir d'une banque suisse la banque
cantonale vaudoise
mais aujourd'hui celle ci dément avoir
effectué la moindre acquisition de
l'action triangle opération que ce soit
pour nous ou pour des terres notamment
la fer et la route alors que
vous ne connaissez pas mais cela n'en a
pas de comptes chez vous roger patrice
pelât a décidé lui de se taire en
attendant les résultats de l'enquêté de
la com la commission des opérations de
bourse mardi prochain où il reste que
dans la journée l affaire a tourné un
affrontement direct offre d'une part le
quotidien le monde et d'autre part
l'elysée qui dément à chaque fois ce
qu'affirme le monde alors chronologie et
résumé de cette polémique
jean-michel mercurol samedi 21 janvier
selon le monde un document mettant en
cause roger patrice pelât pour l'achat
de quarante mille actions triangle
supplémentaire est remis à françois
mitterrand dès vendredi soir information
ni confirmée ni démentie par l'elysée
qui garde un silence total
tout le week-end lundi 23 ou sur coup
deux événements un démenti catégorique
de l'elysée sur l'existence d'un rapport
remis au président et réapparition
soudaine presqu'au même moment de
patrice pelât resté introuvable
jusqu'ici
vous pensiez que
je me cachais je m'empêche pas oublié
silence mais écoutez moi je vous dis je
lèche la commission une bourse perd son
temps drainé le même soir françois
mitterrand s'affiche serein et souriant
lors d'une représentation théâtrale aux
bouffes du nord
étonnante mise en scène commente
aujourd'hui le monde qui révèle que ces
informations viennent d'un service
officielle les renseignements généraux
le monde maintient sa version
malgré un second démenti de l'elysée cet
après midi nous maintenons ces
informations le l'elysée a démenti
deux jours après que nous ayons publié
notre article l'elysée continue de
démentir c'est une ligne bon que je
pense la présence de la république s'est
tracée sur laquelle elle se maintient de
notre côté nous maintenons nos
informations le monde qui s'interrogent
toujours ce soir sur les raisons qui ont
conduit l'elysée à adopter le scénario
du démenti alors après ce nouvel échange
entre le monde et l'elysée donc après
cela nous avons décidé d'inviter le
ministre de l'intérieur pierre joxe qui
t'avait tout ce soir pour répondre à des
questions très précises car il y en a
alors monsieur joxe y at il eu oui ou
non une note de vos services
informant le président de la république
sur la sphère fiche il est non mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que vos services
enquête bien sûr sur ces affaires qui
n'ont je me suis déjà exprimé là dessus
peut-être qu'un jour peut-être peut-être
qu'un jour des services de la police
judiciaire seront chargés par la justice
d'enquêter sur cette affaire
si la commission des opérations de
bourse en décide ainsi
et pour le moment ce qui est vrai c'est
que les renseignements généraux mais
roule même un email leur travail et
coûté déjà le leucate le 14 janvier le
journal le quotidien mettait en cause
monsieur plat 40 ni l'action de plus
quelques jours plus tard l'express
disait vous évoquez la même chose vous
savez il faudrait admettre que c'est pas
parce qu'une information n'est pas
démenti qu'elle devient exact féministe
encore nous et parler de polémique entre
l'elysée
journal le monde il n'y a pas de
polémique et bien une polémique du monde
mais l'elysée des communiqué de quatre
lignes on peut pas être plus laconiques
n'y a pas de polémique
j'aime initial il ya sans doute une
agitation autour de cette affaire qui
est compréhensible parce que c'est une
affaire grave grave août et il ya la
nécessité de la sérénité des organismes
légaux qui sont chargés dire le moment
venu la royère un pêcheur ministre vous
avez question ray des services qui sont
très compétents en la matière savez une
6e qui nous aurait les compétences
économiques c'est normal vous avez aussi
ce qu'on appelle le groupe des enquêtes
réservées qui fut aussi son travail
bon ces gens là aussi sont sur le
dossier
eux aussi peuvent vous donner les
informations mais des informations on
voit les vrais parfaitement normal ce
qui donne l'information bien mais
voulait transmettez au président de la
république je croyais qu'on passe son
temps à transmettre aux prises au mali
des choses qui sont dans les journaux
oui non mais je rêve de ces services qui
eux mêmes des ouvrages mais les stars et
les jolies ce je vous répète oui je vais
faire comme la présidence de la
république je vous répète que les
services de police activement n'enquête
pas sur cette affaire il ne leva le
droit en france c'est la commission de
passe en bourse comme des charges et une
fois pour toutes laissez moi vous dire
que on va parler de démenti aux démentis
il suffit simplement de laisser
fonctionner ceux qui ont la charge de
faire cela alors revenons à la pole et
une fin la politique face aux
affirmations du monde 10 rue ou bien
est-ce que à votre avis le monde
non le monde invente ou bien le monde
est mal informé je m'interroge pourquoi
qui peut imaginer qu'un rapport de yandé
plus rapport j'ai remarqué que c'est une
vision une note non les mots n'ont pas
eu imaginer ex travers des notes
oui sur des choses qu'on trouve déjà
dans les journaux monsieur alors non
mais moi je ne suis pas là pour juger
les journaux je vous ai montré que cette
information apparaissait dans
différentes zones auparavant
je vous répète actuellement on met en
avant vous l'avez dit j'ai noté ce que
vous avez dit les deux français et
uniquement les deux français de fait ils
se sont expliqués de même peut-être pas
assez
peut-être qu'ils le font davantage la
commission
son humour est là pour ça ni vous ni moi
ils ont le droit au respect de leur
personnalité
tant qu'ils ne sont pas accusés ils ne
sont pas accusés tant qu'ils ne sont pas
condamnés on n'a pas le droit de les
juger
et pour le moment la seule chose que je
peux dire c'est qu'il ya une agitation
malsaine et que je comprends que des
journalistes aient envie d'en savoir
plus cela a été six fois au moment où on
ne peut pas en savoir plus on a
maintenant que votre sentiment par
exemple est-ce que vous aurez non non
pas sur la sphère ne suis pas chargé
non pas qu'ils sont là faire elle même
monsieur le ministre mais est ce que
justement vous dites on met en avant
certaines personnes etc
le sentiment qu'il ya une manipulation
je le sentiment que actuellement tout
est focalisé sur deux personnes deux
français uniquement elle ce que sans
doute la suite de l'enquète donnera une
vision complète de la faire à ce moment
là j'aurais un centime j'aurai un
sentiment lorsque la requête aura abouti
se munissent vais certainement dire je
suis terriblement têtu moi aussi bon
alors continuons à nous entendre
voilà je voulais simplement vous
demandez vous le dites donc ce soir
qu'aucun de vous service ne possède
d'informations concernant le sup là et
ce rachat de 40 mille actions qu'on
n'aurait pas vraiment vu qu'un de mes
services n'a d'autres informations que
celles que chacun et glace actuellement
peut entendre bruire dans tous les sens
les informations les plus
contradictoires circulent le même
quotidienne paris qui disait le 14
monsieur plat est mis en cause pour
encore quarante mille titres
le même journal publie le guide ailleurs
et bien non il faut être prudent s'il
vous plaît ou les journalistes vous avez
jusqu'à présent vous avez tenu une
attitude que je crois juste
cette enquête est en cours en revanche
son exploitation politique alors elle a
bien commencé je ne parle pas de vous je
regarde là tous les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition et qui
lorsqu'il était au pouvoir
l affaire des privatisations on m'a
reproché d'avoir parlé un peu vivement à
l'époque parce que c'était des milliards
qui était en cause par des gens qui
étaient au pouvoir sont eux qui manipule
qui en occident ce ministre du budget
aujourd'hui regardez la presse
internationale tout le monde constate
que le christ donne alors dernier le
premier
moment le ministre des finances ne sont
pas en cause les français ont le droit
de savoir et ils seront bientôt ce que
la justice pense de cette affaire
dernière question très vite est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'on est ce
qu'on cherche à nuire au président de la
république à côté
ce que je sais c'est que lorsque chef de
l'état le président de la république qui
dit et ce n est pas un homme d'argent
voir son nom à la une d'un quotidien il
en haut là son ami ou s'il n'avait qu'un
ami un ami qui lui causait bien dit
chagrin je l' ai déjà dit en se mettant
dans une situation pareille ça ne
profite pas au président de la
république ça ne profite pas à la france
pourquoi pas ce qu'on jette la suspicion
sur une affaire d'argent le président
dalvik n'a rien à voir ce que l'opinion
et dans la salle c'est très bien
attendez quelques jours je pense qu'il y
aura un certain nombre de surprises
surtout pour ceux qui se sont engagés
trop vite ce qui n'est pas votre cas je
le reconnais bien volontiers
merci pierre joxe et j'ajoute la
réaction de votre successeur
prédécesseur charles pasqua qui vient au
secours du président effectivement à
dunkerque tout à l'heure monsieur pasqua
en effet dit qu'il serait malvenu de
reprocher au chef de l'état
les actes qu aurait pu faire ses amis de
longue date
autre réaction nous allons l'écouter
celle de rerum prénom barre par dont il
attend lui aussi les résultats de l
enquête de la cob estimant que jusqu'à
présent il n'y avait pas de preuves je
souhaite donc que la lumière soit faite
et en fonction des conclusions de
l'enquêté de la comme s'il y avait dit
que la justice passe mais pour le reste
je me garderai de me mêler à cet
ensemble de comportements et d'attitudes
où les uns accusent les autres souvent
sans preuve c'est ce qui me frappe
beaucoup de rumeurs beaucoup
d'insinuations et jusqu ici pas de
preuve
du moins jusqu'à ce que les instances
spécialisées se soit prononcé alors je
crois qu'il vaut mieux dans cette
affaire ont montré une certaine réserve
je m'exprimerai lorsque tout sera clair
voilà sur cette affaire donc pechiney le
reste de l'actualité d'abord cette
information nous vient de prendre
connaissance d'un instant françois
mitterrand le président de la république
assistera aux obsèques de l'empereur du
japon le président mitterrand annoncé
donc qu'il se rendrait à tokyo le 24
février prochain pour assister à ses
obsèques françois mitterrand et georges
bush 20 minutes de conversation au
téléphone cet après midi entre l'elysée
et la maison blanche c'est george bush
qui a appelé c'était le premier contact
entre les deux chefs d'état depuis
l'installation du président bush
on connaît maintenant les membres du csa
le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel le
président du sénat le président de
l'assemblée et le président de la
république ont présenté leur choix trois
noms pour chacun le président du csa ce
sera jacques goûter explications
stéphane magnier
c'est donc celui qui fut le premier
président de tf1 lors de l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir jacques boutet qui va
guider les premiers pas du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel le csa
il aura à ses côtés trois journalistes
relents fort l'actuel pdg de
radio-france des îles gallard l'ancienne
productrice de dim dam dom et geneviève
guicheney notre consoeur de rtl2
producteur de télévision bertrand
labrusse l'ancien président de la sfp
lui aussi membre de la cncl et igor
barrère dont peu savent qu'il est
également médecin
deux universitaires francis balle auteur
de nombreux livres et monique auger la
faune enfin robert burnel président de
l'union nationale des associations
familiales complètent la liste
tâche difficile il faudra éviter les
pièges qui ont ébranlé la crédibilité de
l'ex cncl mais le csa aura deux atouts
on a privilégié la nomination de
professionnels pour calmer le jeu et
puis les premiers dossiers à traiter
comme le satellite et des f1 sont moins
brûlant que ceux d'il ya deux ans
michel droit à disculper pour l'une des
accusations qui étaient portées contre
lui le juge de rennes a rendu un
non-lieu à propos de l'inculpation de
forfaiture mais il n'y a rien de changé
pour l' affaire de corruption passive
dans laquelle michel droit est aussi
impliquée à l'étranger la sphère vanden
bemden l'ancien premier ministre belge a
bien été enlevée c'est maintenant la
conviction du parquet de bruxelles
ce matin la bsr une mystérieuse
organisation avait envoyé par la poste
une lettre de vdb et sa carte d'identité
isabelle bechler les enquêteurs belges
ont désormais une certitude ce sont bien
ceux qui se cachent derrière
l'appellation de brigade socialistes
révolutionnaires qui ont enlevé paul
vanden boeynants un courrier parvenu ce
matin à la rédaction du quotidien le
soir
la teste il s'agit d'une déclaration
composés aux lettres à cette annonce en
que l'ancien premier ministre est
destiné à une espèce de procès populaire
pour répondre de ses actes une fois que
les 5 millions de francs de sa rançon
auront été distribués aux pauvres seule
preuve sa carte d'identité authentique
et de feu y est écrit de sa main
l'écriture a été reconnue par les
familiers de l'homme d'état il et promet
à ses ravisseurs de respecter ses
engagements de faciliter le paiement de
la rançon tout en doutant que son fils
trop surveillé par la police soit le
meilleur intermédiaire possible ces
documents en revanche n'apporte pas la
preuve que paul vanden boeynants enlevé
voilà dix jours soit toujours vivant
le calme est revenu en argentine l'
attaque menée par deux présumés
guérilleros d'extrême gauche contre une
garnison cette attaque a pris fin en
début d'après midi
les derniers assaillants se sont rendus
il y a trente morts et 50 blessés
michel mompontet après 29 heures de
combat les tanks de l'armée régulière
argentine entre dans la caserne de la
table had
la confusion est alors totale de boutons
mou des soldats panique et vont même
tirer sur d'autres soldats
au dehors la foule crie ma talos tuez
les
39 mans à l'origine de cette attaque
suicide selon le gouvernement argentin
il s'agirait d'un groupuscule d'extrême
gauche voulant s'opposer à la
préparation d'un putsch qui selon eux se
tramait dans cette caserne
difficile pourtant de croire l'extrême
gauche argentine capable d'une telle
action alors que la dictature militaire
la destinée de tous ces chefs dans
quatre mois se tiendront les élections
avec un raul alphonsine plus fragilisée
que jamais coincé entre une extrême
gauche qui peut être se réveille et une
armée qui se veut toujours plus forte
mais cette volonté de puissance avait
conduit l'argentine à vivre durant sept
ans sous la dictature
d'autres informations internationales
tout de suite en bref en images en
commençant par les séismes en union
soviétique
emmanuel vanier
nouveau séisme ce matin en arménie
intensité 6 degrés sur l'échelle de
mercalli qui en compte douze apparemment
pas de victimes
la population avait été avertie à temps
grâce au sismographe mise en place par
les scientifiques américains après le
tremblement de terre du mois de décembre
au tadjikistan on recherche toujours
d'éventuels survivants
trois villages ont été littéralement
enseveli sous 15 mètres de boue le
dernier bilan fait état d'un millier de
morts
exécution ce matin en floride de ted
bundy condamné à la chaise électrique en
1978 pour le viol et le meurtre d'une
fillette de 12 ans après trois requêtes
rejetées par la cour suprême
ted bundy faisaient une dernière
tentative pour obtenir un nouveau sursis
samedi dernier il avoué plusieurs autres
moeurs un dernier recours inutile ce
matin tête vous le dis a été la 106e
personnes exécutées depuis le
rétablissement de la peine de mort aux
etats-unis en 1976
publication à varsovie du rapport
d'autopsié concernant le père stéphane
wiertelak assassiné dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi selon ce rapport la
mort du prêtre est due à une fracture
des vertèbres cervicales une fracture
provoquée par un coup très violent porté
par une personne particulièrement forte
ou bien spécialement entraînés aux
techniques de combat précise le document
la thèse du crime crapuleux semble donc
de moins en moins crédible la sphère de
la petite aurore la justice en appel a
décidé de confier ses enfants à son père
nous vous le disions hier aurore et
cette petite fille de 4 ans déchiré
entre sa famille d'accueil et son père
donc à qui la justice vient de là
confiait hier après le jugement nous
avons fait entendre la détresse de la
famille d'accueil qui a perdu ce soir à
gainsbourg j'ai enquêté auprès du père
et de son avocate
lorsque nous l'avons rencontré il ya
quinze jours aurore dessiner des maisons
elle qui a eu trois foyers en quatre ans
d'existence
hier la justice a choisi de confier la
fillette à son père la famille d'accueil
n'a pas obtenu le droit de visite
qu'elle espérait l'institut de monsieur
madame evrard telle qu'elle ressort du
dossier et notamment de la campagne
qu'ils ont provoquée a confirmé notre
condition et celle de la foule
effectivement il était tout à fait
préjudiciable à l'intérêt d'y enfoncer
définitive je rappelle que la cour
d'appel et la décision et la juridiction
du second degré et
elle l'indiqué sont en train d'arrêter
une décision en dernier ressort la
famille d'accueil a pourtant choisi de
se tourner maintenant vers le tribunal
de grande instance
aurore elle ignore combien on se
l'arrachent ce matin son père l'a
accompagné à l'école comme d'habitude le
rallye de monte-carlo maintenant fin de
la première partie du rallye c'est
l'italien byasen qui est en tête sur une
lancia deuxième une lancia encore mais
c'est un français qui la pilote c'est
didier auriol reportage thierry blancot
fini le suspense pour didier auriol
la déception du jour deux crevaisons
trois minutes 35 de retard sur son
coéquipier le champion du monde niki
biasio auriol conserve tout de même la
seconde place du classement général
ce soir à monaco menacé ici par caen
kounen didier auriol n'a plus qu'un seul
impératif contrer la menace
vatanen performances étonnantes du
finlandais une semaine de reconnaissance
soit quatre fois moins que les autres
concurrents avec une voiture au stade de
prototype le grand art y est tout
simplement fantastique
non j'ai pas fantastique mais pas trop
mal
pas une car ce sont de vieux comme moi
la bonne opération pour biasio sauf
incident mécanique le pilote italien se
dirige tranquillement vers une seconde
victoire mais il reste encore dix
spéciales bac 2 heures de course
non-stop dans la nuit du turini et son
lot de surprises à la fin de ce journal
nous rendrons un hommage de nouveau à
salvador dali comme de très nombreux
admirateurs qui ont commencé à défiler à
figueras et nous nous interrogerons
aussi sur le problème difficile de la
succession du peintre met tout de suite
nous allons directement place de la
concorde à paris vous le savez si vous
habitez paris ou même si vous êtes passé
par là récemment depuis deux ans
précisément toutes les statues de la
place étaient couvertes on les restaurer
et bien ce soir ses statuts sont
dévoilés au public et pour les caméras
d'antenne 2 en direct alors patrick
lecocq vous êtes à la concorde en ce
moment même patrick et c'est vrai que
c'est un événement quasi historique
ancêtres événement à la fois artistique
et historique historique d'abord puisque
c'est exactement il y a deux cents ans
que le roi louis saez décidé la
convocation des états généraux
et vous savez comment cette convocation
des états généraux et cette réunion
s'est terminée elle s'est terminé bien
sûr pas la révolution
et puis donc événements artistiques
également puisque notre présence est
motivée par des raisons esthétiques au
cours de ces dernières années vous le
savez on ne pouvait pratiquement plus
voir les statuts qui entourent la place
de la concorde
elle était miné totalement par la
pollution et bien ses statuts qui avait
perdu
même nous allons maintenant et en quatre
minutes toutes les retrouver au fur et à
mesure il ya huit statues disposées aux
quatre ans de cette place de la concorde
alors pour cet événement historique et
artistique et bien le maire de paris qui
a décidé de placer cette cérémonie comme
point de départ des cérémonies
commémorant le bicentenaire de la
révolution a invité quelques maires les
huit maires des huit sites est
représenté certains sont là monsieur
leroy le maire de lille les maires
bretons au fond présence et nous
l'écouterons bien sûr ces huit statues
avec d'abord nantes et brest
d'abord la statue de nantes celle de
brest nantes assise bien sûr sur un
navire tandis que la statue de brest
repose sur une pièce de canon et tient
dans sa main un gouvernail des statuts
qui ont été refaites entièrement en
moins de 18 mois pour être précis et que
les parisiens et tous les touristes
pourront découvrir cette nuit et surtout
à partir de demain au grand jour un
spectacle qui était prévu et préparé
avec de la pyrotechnie feu d'artifice au
fil de chaque statue et avec l'ensemble
des cuivres d'un guy touvron mais statut
actuellement sont recouvertes certaines
d'entre elles encore de drapeaux
tricolores et ce sont des ballons tenus
par les poulbots de paris qui de 45
secondes en 45 secondes
bon enlever ces drapeaux tricolores qui
ont été placés et nous montrer le
résultat de deux ans de restauration
une restauration qui a coûté fort cher
mais qui rendra à cette place de la
concorde qui a apporté bien des noms
vous le savez dans l'histoire de france
se place louis 15 ensuite place louis
saez puis place de la révolution bien
sûr pour s'appeler à nouveau la syrie 15
pour redevenir en 1928 place oui 16 et
en 1830 place de la concorde un nom
qu'elle n'a pas perdu depuis
après nantes et brest nous avons
découvert bordeaux et rouen
alors je cherche à rien en vous disant
que la statue de bordeaux tu y as un
gage d'une corne d'abondance un écusson
et que de la vigne grimpent le long de
ses statuts sur le dos
patrick lecocq j'imagine j'imagine qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde sur la place de la
concorde absolument superbe on est un
peu dans le noir il a passé la place de
la concorde a été plongée dans le noir
et chacune des statues et éclairé au fur
et à mesure d'abord par des projecteurs
et ensuite par un spectacle
pyrotechnique avant que l'ensemble de la
place de la conclure me soit éclairé et
qui a un feu d'artifice ne soit tiré
sous cérémonie d'ailleurs qui sera assez
brève une quinzaine de minutes tu n'en
fut pour nous qui a environ 3 minutes 30
à 4 minutes le temps de voir les huit
statues qui représente les huit grandes
villes de france qui sont représentées
sur cette place de la concorde et qui
font d'ailleurs le tour de france nous
partons de l'île s'ils voulaient nous
allons vers strasbourg nous descendons
vers lyon ensuite marseille
nous retrouvons bordeaux nous montons
vers nantes et brest
et puis une grande ville n'ont pas de
l'extérieur mais presque de l'intérieur
la ville des négociants la ville des
marchands c'est rouen est d'ailleurs
cette ville de statut de la ville de
rouen porte le caducée qui n'est pas le
cas du cd médecin mais le cas du sien
représentant hermès qui vous le savez
bien sûr avait était le dieu des
voyageurs est le dieu des commerçants
bien sûr mais patrick vous avez appris
quelque chose je suis sûr à des milliers
de parisiens et des millions de
parisiens parce qu'on savait pas que ses
statuts finalement été consacrées
chacune à une ville si elle s'était
consacrée à une ville et c'était le
symbole finalement de l'unité la scène
house avec avant la révolution ne
parlait pas de nations ont parlé y avait
la france le royaume de france est le
symbole d'une nation est née au moment
de la révolution
mais je voudrais vous poser une question
puisque vous m'avez vous même poser une
question est ce que vous savez qui a été
le modèle de la ville de strasbourg pour
un sculpteur extrêmement célèbre puisque
c'était pradier et goûter évidemment
c'est une question piège suis incapable
de vous répondre mon propos c'est une
personnalité très connue je vais vous le
dire c'est juliette drouet a
effectivement je ne sais pas si vous
pouvez revenir au quatrième semaine je
le spectacle ce soir était superbe et
maintenant c'est l'ensemble de la place
de la concorde qui va s'illuminer avec
les huit statues représentant ses rangs
huit grandes capitales régionales bien
merci patrick c'est là dessus que nous
allons vous quitter tous les parisiens
peuvent assister à ce spectacle en ce
moment merci patrick lecocq de nous
avoir fait suivre ce spectacle et
maintenant nous allons à figueras en
espagne c'est là où repose un autre
géant de la culture c'est salvador dali
qui est mort hier vous le savez à 84 ans
des dizaines d'admirateurs ont déjà
défilé aujourd'hui devant le cercueil du
plus célèbre
surréaliste jarre dalmaz enveloppé de
soie blanche visage apaisé le divin
semble dormir
le marquis de dali époux paul n'est plus
de ce monde mais le monde vient à lui
depuis ce matin 6h et jusqu'à demain 15
heures en la chapelle ardente installée
au musée fondation dalit en plein
figueras devant le maître de cadaqués
embaumé presque embellie passe des
milliers de personnes de toute l'espagne
et du reste de l'europe avec et les
registres de signatures en témoigne
beaucoup de français curieux ou ému nous
avons la chance d'être à perpignan donc
c'est assez facile il faut une
demi-heure
d'ailleurs on a été surtout parce qu'il
y aurait beaucoup plus de monde ce matin
pensé faire une cure les lois mais
nomment le bon je ne l'avais pas
tellement au début je trouvais un peu
loufoque mais une fois que j'ai vu le
musée j'ai apprécié mon sujet ni au fil
des heures le nombre des visiteurs ne
cesse d'augmenter c'est l'affluence vers
la petite ville de catalogne parfois les
familles apportent avec elles la
corbeille ou la couronne de l'hommage
dès demain 18 heures après la messe
salvador dali rejoindra sa tombe dans
son musée
là il pourra jamais voir les étoiles à
travers sa chair coupole de verre le
nombril du monde disait-il
et comme pour tous les artistes de cette
envergure le problème de la succession
de dali va se poser elle a déjà été
compliqué pour picasso par exemple vous
en souvenez mais pour dali elle le sera
plus encore vraisemblablement dali
n'avait pas d'héritier direct
il laisse une oeuvre immense mais aussi
toute une série de faux tableaux
les experts les avocats les hommes de
l'art et les hommes de loi travaille
déjà
georges bigot ce tableau la bataille de
tétouan dernières oeuvres de dali en
vente publique asos be a atteint en 1987
13 millions de francs
on peut comprendre que si l'héritage du
peintre se compose de deux ou trois
cents toiles de cette valeur une autre
bataille s'engage celle des héritiers
malgré le secret qui ne se dissipera que
dans quinze jours à l'ouverture du
testament et des tiroirs on peut compter
comme légataire possible la soeur de
dali le musée de figueras le
gouvernement de catalogne et le
gouvernement espagnol
depuis très longtemps mais enfin ça n'a
jamais ça n'avait jamais été définis
d'une façon bureaucratique et ça c'est
très propre de dali et les autorités
comprennent parfaitement ce que
représente l'héritage de dali son
patrimoine pour la culture du pays alors
divisée
je dirais j'emploierai couper en
rondelles là l'oeuvre de dali ce serait
maladroit
alors que si elle peut garder son centre
opérationnel à figueras
ce sera la volonté exécuté exactement la
volonté d'ali le testament sera-t-il
aussi surréaliste que ses toiles
des surprises sont attendues un de ses
serviteurs pourrait être comblé mais sa
soeur risque d'être déshérités la
succession picasso semble à côté de
celle ci un héritage sans histoire le
problème parce que qu'est-ce qui est de
dali et qu'est-ce qu'il épate dali et
vous savez qu'il ya d'une part une masse
deux oeuvres gravées particulièrement
dont on ne sait pas très bien disait
spécial pas m'avancer moi même enfin en
temps le spécialiste il semblerait que
il ya d'une part d europe sont
authentiquement dali d'autres sont
peut-être des reproductions dali dans
son mausolée
le divin dali doit sourire une dernière
fois il crée un mystère dans le monde
entier sans pouvoir s'empêcher d'en
parler à temps la révélation fin de
cette édition tout de suite la météo
avec sophie davant qui est plutôt
optimiste vous allez le voir la dernière
édition ce sera vers 23h30 avec henri
sannier bien sûr à demain 20 heures